well we're joined Now by The General
Secretary of the United Union Sharon
Graham thanks very much for being with
us
we spent an awful lot of time on the
program today talking about Nadeem
zahawi's tax Affairs or loans taken out
by Boris Johnson are you worried that
this is effectively a distraction for
the government totally because it's
woeful listening to this because of
course the big issue or now is the NHS
and what is going to happen in relation
to the NHS and I've heard government
ministers coming on different programs
your programs other programs literally
saying that they are in talks with
unions and there has been no talks with
unions and so we're still in exactly the
same position that we've been in for
weeks there's another strike Tomorrow
there's an escalation of strikes over
the coming weeks and Rishi sunak I have
to say is missing in action I don't know
where he is he should be getting around
the table he is the CEO of this company
if you were talking about negotiating
terms here's the key decision maker it's
clear Stephen Barkley cannot make a
decision now it's either that Rishi
sunak is not up to this job that he
doesn't want to come into the
negotiating room and to do this deal or
there must be another reason as to why
he's allowing this self-harm to happen
to the NHS there have been some talks
though right Stephen Buckley has been
talking to some at union members right
but they're not pay talks and this is
the problem the big issue here is about
pay
um there is an issue where the ambulance
workers the and the nurses the NHS are
saying we need a pay rise the public is
supporting that pay rise as we can see
from surveys and we've got the employer
in this instance the government who will
talk about anything but they won't talk
about paid years pay rise right but
that's not the one that's gone well
that's not what the dispute is about the
dispute is about 2223 but they haven't
made any offer Sophie this is the
scenario I mean I negotiate every day of
my life I'm in the rooms with CEOs all
the time we know what it does and what
has to happen to have deals happen
um this employer being the government is
not interested in doing a deal as far as
the NHS is concerned and I have to say
we are concluding now that there must be
a much more Sinister reason for this
because this level of self-harm is
unprecedented the public are crying out
I came here in a cab this morning and
the cab driver was saying why don't they
just give a pay rise to the NHS
everybody wants that to happen it's
almost like there is another reason for
them doing what they're doing because
it's total incompetence otherwise what
do you think that reason listen well I
think that they are looking to privatize
the NHS genuinely I believe that they're
they're looking as this is the moment
they can privatize the NHS I said when I
was on your program the last time that I
was very concerned about the chancellor
who was the health secretary who wanted
the NHS in the American trade deal and
there was a big fight about making sure
it wasn't in the American trade deal
there is something unusual going on here
that they will not come to the table
there are choices that can be made that
means we can pay for this that is not
there is not a problem about paying with
the fifth richest country in the world
there is something going on here
otherwise they are a level of
incompetence not known I mean because
it's unreal it's a big claim to say the
government is looking to privatize the
NHS and that goes against everything
that they've said about the NHS
remaining free at the point of use I
mean labor a prepared accountants more
private sector involvement in the in the
NHS right now than the government you
know do you have any evidence to back
this up because I guess what they would
say is look at the at the minute we're
spending more on debt interest than
education this is why there has to be
pay restraint we'll actually speak
louder than words to me so words you
know words are cheap
um there is a crisis in the NHS they can
come to the table and negotiate on this
crisis all the general secretaries
including may have said we will be there
any time any place anywhere we'll cancel
any meeting to be there in that room
here's the CEO of this group of workers
and he refuses to come to the table now
it's either that he doesn't know what to
do when he gets to that table I mean
maybe he doesn't know how to negotiate I
don't know maybe it's that there is
another issue going on but we have to
look at what's happening why would they
not be coming to the table and deal with
this issue everyone is crying out for
them to get this issue solved and unless
they solve the issue of workers and the
crisis of workers in NHS and those
people leaving the NHS we will never be
able to get the NHS back on its knees
and they know that how long could these
strikes go on for well I hope that they
are resolved very very quickly and but
the problem is and you know when you're
in a negotiation two parties have to
speak and they have to come out with a
deal and then that deal will go back to
the membership we have not had any deal
to take back to the membership they went
around different Studios Before
Christmas saying they were going to
offer things it was nearly there you
know glimmers of hope I didn't have that
warm fuzzy feeling of hope I have to
tell you because I've seen this many
times before they haven't even offered a
deal so they are they're being
disingenuous by pretending that there
are talks going on about pay
significantly about pay there are
absolutely no talks going on about pay
every General Secretary will tell you
that do you think part of the issue is
that initially some of the proposals
were what the government would describe
as clearly unaffordable 90 for nurses
for example well that tells me they
don't understand negotiation obviously
there is an opening situation where a
claim is tabled
um I think it's really clear that what
we're talking about is a pay rise in the
double-digit pay rise that's what we're
talking about the RCN have already said
they'd meet them halfway I don't know
how much more hints do they want to take
on that and so it's a double-digit pay
rise if they came in the room and they
offered a double-digit pay rise we would
take that back to our members and our
members would make the decision but
they're not doing that they are playing
with words dancing around their Handbags
and they're not coming and doing the
deal they need to do to get the NHS back
working now we're having rolling strikes
in NHS nurses ambulance workers at a
time when we all know the NHS is under a
law depression right
do accept that that is putting people's
lives at risk well I'd say about that is
that their lives are at risk already 500
people a week I mean just think of that
number because we say numbers very
quickly 500 people a week are dying
waiting for ambulances 500 a week that
is unbelievable in a country like ours
people are dying if we don't take this
stand and we don't sort out what's going
on in the NHS it will crash and die and
so therefore this strike yes it's about
pay absolutely 100 it's about pay and I
think people want the NHS to get a pay
rise but it's also about the NHS itself
and it's on its knees unless we can get
more people working in it it will not
survive so it's a strike to save the NHS
as well as get a good pay rise for
workers the strike obviously has an
impact uh too
um that's certainly the view of Amanda
Pritchard the chief executive of NHS
England who said in an interview this
week as the strike action is extended
over long periods of time and as those
dates start coming closer to together it
does get more challenging there is
absolutely no doubt it is clearly having
an impact I think that's obvious
yes absolutely and of course what we do
in strikes and you know this is what we
do across the board in the NHS is that
we put safety guarantees in so I was on
the picket line the West Midlands for
the ambulance dispute I'm on the picket
line tomorrow in the Northwest for the
ambulance dispute and we negotiate
safety cover in relation to those
disputes it's never going to be as good
as it well
if we're talking about 500 people a week
as you say according to the uh you know
acute medicine people they say that that
is that's 500 people a week up to 500
people dying because of delays or
ambulances if ambulance workers go on
strike
that's gonna have an impact but we are
putting in safety levels that mean it
doesn't have as much as an impact and
that is actually the irony here we could
be in a situation which we were on the
21st where it was safer on the 21st than
it was in normal play because we are in
minimum service levels anyway there's
130 000 people missing from the NHS and
to be honest with you Sophie what has to
happen here is quite a simple solution
the government all they need to do is to
come to the table let's do a negotiation
we come out of the room we put it to the
members they ballot and then everyone's
back to work it's a very simple thing
this has been drawn out for weeks and
weeks and weeks and you have to think is
this deliberate is it deliberate are you
saying that ministers are effectively
lying then when they say that they are
yes I am saying that and the ministers
have been lying on a number of issues
and normally I wouldn't use that word
you know it's not really a word that we
would use we tend to dance around that
word a lot but I have to tell you the
the stuff that's been said about
ambulance workers and them not covering
minimum safety levels on dispute was a
lie and I'll say very clearly it was a
lie the stuff that's been trotted out I
did something last week and the
government's response was we're in talks
that is a lie they are absolutely not in
Pay talks and this is the problem that
we haven't got an honest partner at the
other side of the table you know
normally you go into a negotiation yes
you have archibaldi you don't always
agree you don't get everything you want
that is life but you know that the
person on the other side of the table
wants resolution I'm negotiating with
somebody at the moment that I don't
think wants resolution and that's a real
problem I'll have to say listening like
whatever the you know the truth listen
to you now it does feel like that deal
is an awful long way off um just before
I spoke to you I respected of Labor I
was trying to get a sense about what
labor would do if they were in
government right now what pay rise they
would see is fair he said that you know
he's not going to give a number it that
would be meaningless it wouldn't make
any difference is he right or do you
think it would be helpful if labor
actually would be clear on what they
would do well look labor aren't in
government so he's right about that but
obviously they're in opposition so I
have to say you know I would prefer
labor to be in government I think they
would be far better on the NHS and a
number of things but actually this is a
moment to come out in my opinion I think
they should come out to say that they
would give the NHS a pay rise and it
would be 10 I think that just needs to
be said because everybody knows what
we're talking about we're all pretending
we don't know the figure I think they
need to do that because what that will
do then is I've never been stepped with
the public I have to tell you but also
it would say to the government the
opposition is asking for the same thing
if they're in your seats they would do
the same thing and it's really important
because this is important because people
keep using it as a reason it can be
afforded there are ways to do it there
are choices to be made that means this
can be why do you think labor aren't
coming out and saying that
well he'll they'll have to answer that I
mean you know for me I think what people
are looking for is is leadership you
know whenever I go into negotiation
whenever I'm in a room what you want
people to be is clear this is what I
will do this is what we want and you
think we need labor isn't showing
leadership well I think that they are
trying to be too cautious about it you
know and that's you know when you're in
a situation we're in crisis now this is
not the time for being cautious this is
the time to show real leadership and in
opposition you can show leadership so
I'd like them to come out and say yes
they support the pay rise and yes it
would be a pay rise in the region of 10
I don't see any problem with them doing
that okay you've been very clear on the
program this morning you have to say at
10 thank you very much